magnus grew up
in the in the 90s it was quite a cute
cute boy magnus was born in november
1990
he already had a sister
ellen he was one and a half years old we
would trade off
me playing with more girly things and
getting him to join playing with dolls
he loved reading about the
commune flags the number of inhabitants
and he would make me quiz him it's
john deere my wife and i we considered
our children to be absolutely normal in
many respects basically
now later i understand that they had
some special traits
and clearly magnus he was into
concentrating for hours at the time
doing various tasks whether it was legos
or
chess or math yeah it was
fun to have some friends over but i
think his main occupation was
a new big lego do any chess pictures in
here or is this too early this is too
early
i tried to teach magnus and his older
sister
chess when he was four and a half and
then
it was so difficult for them if i had
any
aspirations for the kids basically that
that went
all the way uh during the first year or
two
fortunately because it turned out that
chess was much more difficult
than i had understood basically and
magnus started becoming really
interested in chess at seven and a half
because he wanted to beat his older
sister he wanted to play one
game against me when we were at our
cabin up in the mountains
and i agreed after some pressure from
him and dad
and that was the first time he beat me i
rediscovered that okay he has a talent
for chess
when he was eight and a half that was
his first tournament overall
he came 11th i think a year later he won
this group
here his grandfather
joined him to iceland that was one of
his first kind of
important victories chess was very much
his life from
from the age of eight
so i have to become a grandmaster this
year and is that realistic
i think quite realistic
he struggled a bit in the autumn trying
to take gm norms
that turned out to be difficult for some
months but then
we had a month break and during that
month
it seemed that everything he had learned
during the autumn
matured in a way he came back in january
clearly with grandmaster level strength
it became really big when we were in
iceland
uh in 2004 and he played kasparov in
cardboard
gary casparo was ranked number one in
the world minus
somehow tricked him in the opening it is
wed in hell of a town
it was so weird with all the media it
was the first time i think we
experienced that that
the pressure was so high from outside
dad was getting more and more excited
when he played against kasparov and we
were like oh my god is
is she actually not losing i still very
much remember
the the the nervousness that i felt on
the day
on the game where i finally got the
title and my
opponent i think offered a draw in in a
somewhat worse position and
frankly i mean i couldn't have uh
couldn't have taken the draw any faster
we went to celebrate at mcdonald's
which was like not like where we would
go to eat every day and even got
ice cream so proud dad
that's the international grandmaster
title
diploma that he received from fida so at
13 he became one of the
youngest ever
[Music]
it's funny to think of that it's almost
17
years ago i've been now groundmaster for
much longer than i haven't
i have worked with him since 2009.
minus was then 19. what was he like he
was a bit different from now
actually i think it was quite shy it's
difficult to
get him to do things that he wasn't
used to do when he started to get
recognized on the streets more often in
oslo that
that did not go down very well with him
but i think he was really happy that
normal people who would not usually
follow chess
being interested in in it i think that's
what he thought was really great about
it if i were to become world champion
that would be great
magnus carlsen this is his first
world championship match
this was a larger than life experience
you have this
exotic feel the smells
the noise it's so overwhelming
and together with hundreds of
journalists
it was such an uh mesmerizing
experience a team of grandmasters knows
everything about magna skulls
and they're off
i think i said after the match that well
now i can die
we had a nice celebration and it was a
very happy night for everyone involved
when he won in the end
but at that point he he he was already
there mentally in a way i mean
this was his to win it was like a force
[Music]
2018 carano that was a tough one
you had a great year i didn't and it
felt
when we were playing like we were equals
the other matches it's felt like
losing is simply not an option it cannot
happen obviously that's
not an attitude that is good if you want
to have
an enjoyable experience the match in
london was an equal match and
if i'd lost it would have hurt a great
deal but
still it didn't feel like it was
impossible
you can just feel it when your intuition
doesn't work
it's just the feeling of something's
gone horribly horribly wrong
i think that's something of the most
stressful that can be in sports to
sit there three weeks against the same
opponent and
needing to have a good sleep every night
and it's so stressful
so much nerves i'm not at all able to
understand how he's
able to play under that pressure and
those conditions at all because
it's inhumane after i gained the title
i didn't want to lose it i'm not
necessarily that happy that i have it i
just would be very
unhappy to not have it then the first
you have something to achieve that you
haven't achieved before
after that you either repeat or
fall back down and psychologically
that's much more difficult
for how long do you see yourself
motivated now to keep
defend your title i will most probably
play in
2021 and if i were to win
i have no idea whether i would play the
next one
[Music]
[Music]
foreign